[ __ ] alter fast bis auf fast leute dass
es so knapp ist so knapp
us kids und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen format ich spiele heute die erste
folge von better together zusammen mit
krankhafter der ist mein erster gast
worum es geht in diesem projekt ist ein
format werde ich gleich erzählen
wir spielen hier erst mal hallo herr im
allgemeinen team survival games und ich
werde immer mit abwechselnden partnern
hier dieses teams spielen weil ich
einfach richtig viel spaß daran hast du
jetzt bisschen taktisch zu spielen teams
zweifel games im allgemeinen sich das
ein bisschen abzustimmen für mich mega
cool und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
machen wir mal eine serie daraus wenn
das für übermacht aus besucher danke wie
sich sogar weiter haben aber eine homo
und max ist mein erster gast und ich
habe schon ein paar andere gäste
eingeplant zum beispiel die natur ist
das nein zum beispiel mit euch das mal
machen mit logos auch schon abgesprochen
und da könnt ihr euch auf einiges freuen
dich das ist richtig richtig cool und
ihr könnt auch gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
sie hat mit mir aufnehmen soll achtung
das sind ganz viele leute gehen wir
erstmal lpb hacker sogar hocker oder
nein hacker also hhl aber nichts um ihn
irgendwie in die köpfe rein zu fuß
von bardo hacker ihr links und
gelegentlich gerichtshof wechselberger
es irgendwie geschafft obwohl embargo
hätte viel gang gegen jakob aber hier
habe ich die bauwerke
auseinandergenommen
als was besseres als ein holz bin ich ja
die apex direkt weiter gutes einzige was
ein bisschen ärgerlich weiß dass man es
nicht immer geschafft hat mit seinem
wunschteam partner im team zum beispiel
bei leute ich muss euch noch erzählen
für alle die es nicht wussten es gab
auch komme hd punkt net also auf dem
forum im forum gab es eine abstimmung
da ging es darum was die leute so von
den neuen spielmodus halten weil sich
keine ahnung community mega viele
beschwert haben dass man jetzt nicht
mehr
20.000 leute teams machen kann man keine
klären wo es mehr austragen kann
das gesagt okay machen abstimmung
jetzt haben sich 40 prozent gegen die
neu gingen dann modus ausgesprochen
und ja keine ahnung aber die mehrzahl
wahrscheinlich für den 9
und das team wir natürlich niemand
enttäuschen deswegen haben sie jetzt
eine ganz neue regelung eingeführt ich
weiß nicht ob es dauerhaft ohne
farbliche teams und ohne ohne also
schaden dem eigenen partner zuzufügen
gehen wird momentan kann man das ja noch
also jetzt jetzt sieht man ja quasi
komplett ohne plug-in so weil man
einfach ist einfach ein ganz normales
weißes wunder nur das vom server aus
erlaubt ist davor gab es ja immer diese
teams und da kommt man sich innerhalb
der teams nicht nicht schaden zufügen
und man konnte achtung lassen
links darf alles aktiviert und man
konnte innerhalb der teams nicht mit dem
kompass getrackt werden so das haben
jetzt wieder abgestellt
keine ahnung warum aber ihr könnt ihr
gerne mal die kommentare schreiben was
davon haltet vielleicht hätte man hätte
eine ganz lustige
zwar sie könnten irgendwie so ein
plug-in machen dass man wenn man
schichtet und rechts klicks macht
irgendwie auf dem spiel das sich dann
also dass derjenige in anderen
teampartner wird und das mit dem dann
das mit dem pvp aus ist und das man halt
auch andere leute nicht retten konnten
sind dann bist du ganz nett aber nicht
eine handhabe haben nein zu sagen dass
ich alles sieht auf den kliniken
diese haben oder wenn irgendwie der mann
den brand ein diamant hast oder niesen
da ich hab nur diamanten sagt die sind
leider nicht kompatibel mit mac os x wo
können wir leute noch vacation am hangar
am hangar symbol
13 ich habe schon 28 oder
sprachstörungen 28 frey leiter
übertreiben schon ein nach dem anderen
ich kriege ja völlig auf schmerzmittel
anfrage wieder deine tage da muss ich
erstmal schlagen euch meine tage haben
ja genau mit dem bistum setze die spitze
gesteuert
ich hab dich nicht gekommen
dahinter die gegner man danach wie
bleiben wir haben ja ich finde mich im
allgemeinen ganz spannend zu schauen so
mit welchem partner kann man gut ihn
wäre es besser in pvp vielleicht auch
als vorbereitung für war was dann kommt
dass man so ein paar war teilnehmer
eingeht so patrick oder diesen ein thema
das geschlecht der mit der aktion
gespielt
es war eine art noch mit der wald
gespielt dann frage ich aber war ihr
könnt euch gerne kreativ unter dem namen
die kommentare schreiben ich versucht
dann die leute ran zu holen und du bist
du jetzt am ja ok und die wird nicht
selbst schuld arisch nimmt ihr team auch
nicht ab sofort ist alles offen sonst
würde ich jetzt ich würde ich in einer
sekunde retten könnt junge ich für dich
weg weiter
erstmals kommt ein bisschen pc kommt ihr
zu 200 frames michael 200.000 leitung
bio
er sieht da kommt ein da kommt zweite
beim zweiten konzert bin hier oben
polycom com in die schuhe gelaufen kommt
mal runter in die scheune ist die offene
ausgerüstet hat jetzt kurz weg gehen
musste bedeute kein waren ja du läufst
du mich reinalter lebst du noch ja aber
nicht nur halben herzen diesen direkten
familie einer sind bei mir der andere
hinter dir okay da müssen wir müssen
rennen und die dann 11 auseinandernehmen
so schnell wie alter das fahrrad eben
echt wissen suboptimal
ich hab' ich hab dich einmal erwünscht
ich habe hart und man weiß auch immer
mehr oder was immer noch weiterhin mir
du wolltest schauen wir bleiben
die zurück
verdammt einfach
hat der pfeile der todesfall des west
berlin zehn stücke nicht überlebt
überlebt mit überlebt da kommst du ihm
den weg ab hast du ein bisschen dem
gegner okay geht auf mich ja geht auf
mich wartete oroya castro des priesters
der brand gesetzt erlebst du na ja also
ich brenne gerade ich bin auf
dreieinhalb herzen wie dort dem fall auf
mich warten track den anderen komponiere
keinen bogen
mein lieber mann behält ist
mikrofonkabel hinter zur ein alter war
lass mich folgen das nicht verwehrt
ich bin froh dass du ich habe auch hier
war kalter wir müssen sie an und über
junge dass erstmals ein zeichen sein hut
nun der red bull 1 und hat in altenstadt
hat er allerdings gedruckt wird er
erschießt ein ausweichen aus welcher aus
welchen ausweisen
jetzt jetzt weiter hat er in bogen
also er zumindest nicht beschlossen wenn
sie jetzt noch ein anderer einmischen
müssen auch wissen ja okay jetzt alte
wie wir das noch gedreht haben sie das
ist segen und kran abgebaut
doch wir müssen wir noch ein bisschen
läuft junge in den gesprächen habe ich
noch einholte ich leider nicht
die leute sind dann noch ein buckel der
typ hat ja nichts dieser ja nicht
irgendwer ich gehe mal dass switch keine
angst hat oder werden
yannick hat nichts jannik ist ja noch
einer
da ist der ksc wasser börse okay das war
jetzt auch relativ hart für ihn
aber ja sonst das ist wieder mal auf
ganz harmonisch so beim letzten also bei
dem backen was kurz davor nach außen
server war dass das man als team
gewinnen und ja er das war echt cool da
kommt man konnte noch als team gewinnen
jetzt haben es auch so geschafft also
die erste folge von better together hier
mit granie ist so ein gut verlaufen wir
haben die runde gewonnen
aber solange es diesen team sieht nicht
mehr gibt kann er immer noch ein
spannendes 13 zu machen am ende erwarten
beim 1
diese anspannung bei uns als wir keine
beide werke alter fast bis auf fast
leute dass es so knapp ist so knapp
alter ja jetzt versteckt er sich weil
ich meine anteile verschossen habe weil
ich zufällig zu retten alter ja wohl
jetzt dreieinhalb alter leute mit
schlechteren pc und schlechten ping
geworden
danke aber auf jeden fall auch kate
jetzt an max der mir mehrmals den arsch
gerettet hat in der runde und ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen wenn er mehr waffen
wollte lasst einfach mal ein like da
schreibt man die kommentare mit wem er
mich kämpfen sehen wollt seite an seite
oder will ich sagen bis zum nächsten
video haut rein macht's gut
und übrigens 10 kommt rein